in a successful couple here's what they
do the minute they sense that they're
getting flooded one of them will call
for a break and say when they'll come
back then come back at the designated
time when you're calmer and the
conversation will look like you've just
had a brain transplant it might already
have come across some of the research
that the gotmans have done they are
world famous researchers in the field of
relationships and divorce and marital
satisfaction a lot of people will
apologize almost immediately and that
doesn't work either and the reason is
because you haven't heard your partners
experience of the fight so you don't
really know what you're apologizing for
there's a bunch of super interesting
research they've done in the love lab
where they analyze the interactions
between different couples and they use
those to predict divorce rates further
down the line now that we know what can
create a successful relationship based
on the couples that we studied and there
were over 3 000 of them we now can help
help couples succeed in the future in
their relationship genuinely these guys
are some of the most famous people in
the world when it comes to the field of
relationship research and so it was so
exciting during this conversation in the
conversation we talk a lot about all of
these topics like how to sustain love in
a relationship what are the things that
predict divorce in married couples what
are the practical things that we can do
in our romantic lives to be more
intentional and effective in the way
that we show up in our relationships
very close friendships your
relationships with your children and
your love relationships if the
relationships were high in quality and
the marriage really made them happy they
would live 10 to 15 years longer
at the moment according to the YouTube
analytics 81 of you who are watching
this on YouTube have not yet hit the
Subscribe button and so if you're for
example in the now 81 of people who are
watching this on YouTube but who are not
subscribed to the channel I would love
it if you could do so and would be
awesome to get that number down to 50
and it would be cool to get like 50 50
sub non-sub ratio just just for fun so
guys thank you so much for coming on the
podcast like absolutely fantastic having
you here been a long time admirer of
your guys's work and and in particular
your book uh eight dates is something
that my girlfriend and I are going
through at the moment
um so yeah thank you thank you for
everything that you've done in the world
of kind of being more intentional about
relationships so I'm super excited to
have this conversation oh thank you so
much Ellie we're really happy to have
the opportunity right
this is gonna be fun so um I'd love to
start off by addressing I guess
you know a lot of people listening to
this or if you click on this in our in
the podcast player or on YouTube might
be thinking you know it's a bit intense
talking about relationships and writing
books about relationships and aren't
relationships and love supposed to be
more of a instinctual thing where it
kind of comes naturally to people why
why do we need all this over analysis
and overthinking about relationships
that's a great question uh first of all
because all that good romance uh
beautiful you know stars in the sky Moon
above uh is all about chemistry it's all
about uh hormonal attraction to begin
with uh and then getting to know one
another and as the relationship deepens
up come the patterns that typically
people may have absorbed from their
childhood or from other relationships
that they then
um use to work out conflicts to develop
friendship and so on uh with their
partner and a lot of times uh what they
do doesn't work and it creates sometimes
a lot of frustration pain anger and so
on and uh John in his Brilliance being a
Pioneer back in the 70s figured out
slowly but surely over the years what
really makes relationships work work and
what unfortunately makes them fail
so this was research I did with Robert
Levinson right who's a psychology
professor at UC Berkeley and I did that
work together
right and so uh now that we know uh what
can create a successful relationship not
based on us by any means but based on uh
the couples that we studied and there
were over 3 000 of them we now can help
people by uh creating interventions
which we've done to change how people
relate to one another if it's not
working in order to really help couples
succeed in the future in their
relationship right hmm
how how do you analyze these three
thousand couples like what's the what's
the research methodology here
well it's it's really very simple uh
what we did was first of all get a very
broad sample representative sample of
the in the places we did the research in
the cities and rural areas we did the
research and then we had couples just
come into the lab after being apart for
eight hours talk about how their day
went we videotaped them
and uh while they were talking we had
synchronized physiological data we
collected from them sort of measuring
heart rate respiration blood velocity
things like that and uh then they talked
about an area of conflict that they
hadn't resolved and then we showed them
their tapes and they let us know what
they were feeling every second
and we interviewed them about the
history of their relationship and so on
and then you know for the first 25 years
Bob Levinson and I didn't help anybody
we just tried to find out
are there masters of relationships are
there disasters how are they different
you know and the answer was uh those
differences that we discovered between
the Masters and the disasters actually
replicated over time and you know we
spent a Dozen Years studying gay and
lesbian couples in this using the same
methods and and looking across the whole
life course from couples dating up
through couples in their in their late
80s
um so that's the research
that Bob and I did before Julie and I
got together and she's a very
experienced and talented therapist and
so we started designing interventions
based on all that ability to predict so
well the future of a relationship
and then tested the intervention and now
almost 50 years later we have a set of
interventions that really do help
couples
fantastic so I guess
um that kind of begs the question like
what are the things that predict whether
a relationship is going to work or be
happy and what are the things that sort
of Herald the disaster and in a
relationship
now one of the things that Bob and I
found right away is we just looked at
how positive people were when they
talked to each other how affectionate
how much they laughed together
um interest in one another curiosity
versus hostility anger you know
contempt sadness and disgust and we just
took a ratio of how many seconds of
positive the motion was were there
compared to negative emotion and we
discovered that the Masters even in
Conflict had five times as much positive
emotion as negative
whereas the disasters that ratio of
positive to negative average 0.8 is just
a little bit more negativity and
positivity so that was one of our first
discoveries and then we asked are there
some negative things that are more
predictive than others and we came up
with the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
and Julie can explain what that is if
you want okay sure
um so these are the great big predictors
uh that can predict with over 90 percent
accuracy six years down the road where
are you going to be you're going to be
together happily with your partner
unhappily or will you already be
separated and divorced so the first one
is criticism and all of us are familiar
with that one there's no such thing as
constructive criticism none so when
you're what do you mean yeah when your
boss tries to critically uh
tell you feedback that's not a good
thing so what criticism means is blaming
a problem between you on a character
flaw of your partner so some examples of
that are you're so lazy you wouldn't
think of cleaning up the kitchen why are
you so uh irresponsible you're always
postponing how long it takes to pay the
bills you know what's happening with you
what's wrong with you it's one of the
great criticisms how are you supposed to
answer that you know it's saying you in
general are wrong so those are
criticisms and they hurt and the natural
response to that is the second Horseman
called defensiveness and defensiveness
we're familiar with too there's two
types one is whining like I did two pay
the bills on time or counter attack oh
yeah well when was the last time you
took the car in for repair you know it's
a counter attack
so that's defensiveness we have
criticism defensiveness the third is
really the sulfuric acid for a
relationship it's called contempt and
what we mean by contempt is its
criticism too but from a place of moral
superiority so it includes some scorn
some disgust it's often expressed
through sarcasm
um like oh yeah I'm sure you picked up
the tickets ha you know contempt uh is
also name-calling all those horrible
names when we get very angry that we'll
call somebody could be mockery also ooh
you're so scared you know that kind of
stuff
so contempt is horrible and it not only
is the strongest predictor of
relationship demise
contempt also destroy raise the immune
system of the listener we discovered
that in 15 minutes of conflict the
number of times a listener heard
something contemptuous predicted how
many infectious illnesses they would
have in the coming years right isn't
that amazing so the immune system
suppresses of corer fights off viruses
colds flus tumors right and the people
who experience more contempt got sicker
over time so that was scary finally the
fourth Horseman is what we call
stonewalling and stonewalling is when
one partner completely shuts down
absolutely gives no response to the
person pretends they're not even there
we'll sit there but not give any nod of
the head anything verbal and that's
really related to another Finding of
ours about
physiological flooding which John can
explain but that what we call
stonewalling turning into a stone wall
in the middle of a conversation is our
fourth Horseman right so the the
physiology was very predictive and uh
and what we found was that when people's
heart rate gets above 100 beats a minute
or if you're an athlete 80 beats a
minute we start secreting our two stress
hormones cortisol and adrenaline and
that shuts down the ability to listen
people repeat themselves they think
they're being more persuasive when they
ill instead of you know talking quietly
they you know they really escalate their
behavior and they can't listen very well
they can't take in any new information
so the physiology is very important
because once people are secreting those
two stress hormones they you know the
conversation might as well be over
because it nobody makes any advance they
don't get creative as problem solvers
and so on yeah another word for this is
fight or flight
and I'm sure you know your listeners
have heard of that that's what we're
talking about
so when you're facing your partner
it feels like you're facing a
saber-toothed tiger
so in that context let's say you're in
the middle of uh I don't know a a an
argument with your partner and you're
finding yourself feeling those triggers
of fight or flights what do you do in
that context
in order to succeed or in order to fail
which one to leave
let's say let's say both what does
success and what does fail look like
like what what are the kind of options
that we have in this in this context
okay so fail looks like staying there in
the conversation when you're in fight or
flight uh and what happens is you
escalate you get louder you repeat
yourself you know Ad nauseam uh you
start to move into more criticism more
contempt you can't think straight you
don't hear your partner at all so
nothing you say is a response to your
partner you're just yelling your own
point of view maybe maybe even getting
physical in the worst cases in a
successful couple here's what they do
the minute they sense that they're
getting flooded in fight or flight one
of them will call for a break and and
say when they ask for a break when
they'll come back to talk about the
conversation you know that topic again
so they'll say something like honey I've
got to take a break I'll be back in an
hour then let's talk again
that way they don't leave the other
person feeling abandoned and not knowing
if they're ever going to talk about it
again then when the partners separate
into separate quarters uh they each do
something that is self-soothing
not think about the fight because if
they think about it they'll stay
escalated but do something else distract
yourself read a magazine a book listen
to music meditation go for a run you
know all kinds of things you can do to
self-soothe take a bath and then come
back at the designated time when you're
calmer and a way to tell if you're
calmer is take your heart rate and if
your heart rate is back down to normal
then you're good if it's not back go
back to your partner anyway and ask for
more time
and give a second time it'll return
until you can talk calmly with one
another and the conversation will look
like you've just had a brain transplant
hmm
I guess
I guess we've all been in cases where in
the moment
like someone might be listening to this
or have read one of the books and then
but in in the moment when you're in that
adrenaline cortisol State your kind of
rational thinking goes out the window
and you almost like forget that oh I
should I should do this kind of thing I
should take a breath I should pause do
you guys have any any strategies that
people can use to almost like recognize
her in that state or like in in that
moment to override the Nash the I guess
default instinctive emotional response
to continue to lash out
mm-hmm yeah you know that's such a good
question ali
um what I ask my clients to do and what
I try and practice myself is
um pay attention when I am first getting
escalated or flooded it's really
important for me to know what are the
signals inside my body that tell me I'm
starting to get flooded so you know
you're not going to maybe be able to
recognize all this stuff the first time
but pay attention some people will have
their jog it tight their breathing it
shallow their chests feel tight or they
may feel kicked in the gut maybe their
fists start clenching you know there
will be signals each person uniquely has
when they're starting to get flooded and
what are yours what are mine yeah oh I
never get flooded honey that's such a
laugh okay so mine are typically
um I'll feel heat rising from my belly
and I'll feel very very very hot
throughout the trunk of my body it's
like you know my temperature's just gone
up 20 degrees how about yours
yeah I think uh I think for me
um when I find myself repeating myself
and I know I'm gonna I'm gonna get
flooded and for me it's a constriction
in my throat that lets me know that I'm
getting flooded when this gets tight
here and I know oh boy you know I should
take a break right yeah right that's my
signal and we've had many opportunities
to practice
it's a very positive way of looking at
it yeah I think I think for me it's when
like as you were describing that for me
I think it's when I find myself
in debate mode where I'm just sort of
imploring the other person to just like
surely you could like surely you can see
that you're just being unreasonable here
or you know that kind of stuff and like
oh hang on I love it surely you could
see like what's the matter with you are
you so dumb that you can't see this I
love it I'm gonna practice that one
really you can see the logic of my
position I'm so smart
that's
um on that note
um actually I've I've I've got a
question about this but before we before
we go there we we talked about the four
horsemen let's say someone's listening
to this or watching this and they're
thinking oh damn you know I'm I've
definitely got some of one or more of
those in my relationship
what are the actions that someone can
take if they recognize that their
relationship is sort of falling into one
of these four horsemen well one of the
best things uh that you can do
um we call processing a regrettable
incident
now here's what that means this is a
particular Intervention when you've had
a really bad fight where some of those
four horsemen have thundered through the
conversation
um it's really important to go back with
your partner and talk about what
happened in the in the way that you
communicated what went wrong in the way
you communicated and then apologize for
it and we have a five-step process for
this where each person names their
feelings that they had during the
regrettable incident then they narrate
their point of view about what
transpired and needless to say there's
always two points of view and they could
feel like they're on opposite planets
but they're both valid they're both
right so each one presents their point
of view the other one summarizes what
they just heard the partner say and
gives a few words of validation like I
get it I can see how you would have felt
that way and then third they talk about
what may have gotten triggered for them
and triggers mean feelings that come up
for you during a fight or regrettable
incident that are the same feelings you
may have had long before this
relationship that may have started in
childhood or in former relationship
and those in can include things like
abandonment rejection feeling judged
feeling frightened those kinds of old
feelings you've been carrying inside you
your whole life perhaps so you talk
about those triggers and what stories go
with those from your past you share one
of those
so your partner really understands
better
the scars that you carry inside from old
experiences uh and can try to avoid
triggering those and then the fifth step
is to talk about one thing you can do
differently and one thing your partner
can do differently to avoid something
like this from happening again
that's how you process a regrettable
incident
how how long afterwards should you would
you recommend waiting to process a
regrettable incident are we talking like
the same day or like in a couple days
from now like what what's the time
period are we thinking
well it can be
um whenever as long as it's not
immediately afterwards so some people
won't know they're supposed to do this
and then they'll go back and process
something 20 years later 15 years later
the way that you know you need to
process it is that it still festers in
your mind when you think about it you
know you can still feel the awful
feelings of that event that means you
need to process it but with that said
you have to be very calm when you sit
down and process and I like to tell
people imagine that you're in the upper
balcony of a theater after act one of a
play that play down on stage was the two
of you fighting and you're talking to
your partner about what happened during
act one that's the kind of calmness you
need to have before you talk
nice is there a
to what extent is there utility in
talking things out at the time
um like you know we've just had a had an
argument I'm kind of upset she's kind of
upset
do we just like continue for the rest of
the day as if all right cool let's park
this and then carry on with our day do
we kind of get time apart like how do we
deal with it like let's say that evening
or that day before we are both in that
state of calm to be able to discuss it
maybe tomorrow or the day after
uh okay so can you talk about it
immediately afterwards is that what
you're asking
it's not yeah what do you mean while the
emotions are still like still they're
not quite at that calm level where you
can discuss it fully calmly
I wouldn't do it I wouldn't do it
because it's so easy to slide into the
old argument again you'll slide right
back into the fight
um and also a lot of people will
apologize almost immediately and that
doesn't work either and the reason is
because you haven't heard your partner's
experience of the fight enough to know
how your behavior impacted them so you
don't really know what you're
apologizing for until you've heard the
story of your partner's experience and
you've been able to share yours too
because usually both people in some way
are responsible for what happened not
always but often
that's great
um already got a very actionable point
I'm going to take away from this
conversation so thank you
when when we were talking earlier we we
we kind of joked about like me being
like uh hey can't you just see how how
wrong you are and it there's
there's a bit of a I've I find
hmm
emotions versus logic
I wanted to talk about that when and and
and and I guess you know one of the
things I wanted to ask was um you guys
have a book The Man's Guide to women and
it's very unfashionable these days to
even begin to suggest that Men Are from
Mars and women are from Venus and men
are like this and women are like that
kind of thing
um but one of the things that often
well certainly in in my relationship and
most that I know there's there seems to
be this
um kind of balancing act between one
party wanting to be very logical about
like okay X LED to y letter to Z
therefore ABC and the other party being
I guess more in touch with their
emotions how do you guys kind of
navigate the whole logic versus emotions
territory I guess in particular when it
comes to
um regrettable incidents arguments
fights whatever we want to call it
yeah um
you know the
logic versus emotion kind of thing is is
a false debate because you can be very
logical and still be emotional and in
fact
we need our emotions to problem solve
creatively we need to know what we feel
so we have to
we have to get in touch with our
intuitions
so just because we're emotional doesn't
mean we can't be logical as well at the
same time so that's a false dichotomy
between emotional and rational so we can
be very rational and still be emotional
it's very important that we listen to
the emotional part
of
what what our partners
perceptions are and how they make our
partner feel because if we don't listen
to the emotions then they won't feel
understood they won't feel respected and
so we have to develop that uh competence
to really see and perceive emotions
and if we ignore emotions
the repair we try to make uh during
conflict is not going to work if it's
all very cognitive and you know
intellectual and we're not really taking
into account our feelings and our
partners feelings we won't solve the
problem it just won't work so emotions
have to be understood recognized and
validated we have to see the logic of
the emotion for our partner let me add
something
um so the intervention that we are
talking about processing a regrettable
incident we have a booklet for that a
little booklet that guides you through
this five-step process I just described
and the first step has feelings and it's
a list of feelings all the different
kinds of feelings there's about I don't
know 50 60 of them that are listed and
each person goes through the list saying
out loud any of the feelings on the list
that they had during the incident and
the thing that's interesting is we've
never ever had anyone man or woman not
mention a feeling you know so I think
you know there's also this myth that men
are more logical than women and women
are more emotional it's absolutely a lie
it's just not true at all men have just
as many feelings as women
um and it's interesting because in our
culture we have been socialized uh in
different ways so for women it's not
okay for women to express anger that's
not okay they'll be called the b word
right if they express anger they're not
just angry they're a bad person in this
way for men they're not really allowed
to express the more vulnerable feelings
like fear worry
sadness you know anxiety nope that's not
okay anger's fine but nothing else is
so we have to realize that all of us
whatever gender we are or mixed gender
we are uh feeling beings
we all have emotions it's just a matter
of recognizing them and naming
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is huel now
this is very exciting because I've
actually been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. I started eating Hill in my
fifth year of medical school and I've
been using heal regularly ever since
because you know I like to be productive
I you know my calendar is full with a
lot of things and often I don't have the
time or don't make the time to have a
particularly healthy breakfast or a
particularly healthy lunch and heal is
fantastic for those occasions because
it's 400 calories they've got tons and
tons of different flavors my favorite
flavor is salted caramel because for
that you get 400 calories you also get
40 grams of protein super hard to get
enough protein in my diet these days
especially with trying to get hinge and
working out cure to make sure that I get
at least those 40 grams in the 400
calories and it's got 26 different
vitamins and minerals which really helps
with the whole healthy balanced diet
thing as well now I don't use heal with
every meal I wouldn't recommend using it
with every meal but in those occasions
where you find yourself reaching for a
very unhealthy snack we're about to
order a really unhealthy takeaway it's
just absolutely fantastic being able to
have the option now I use the heel black
edition in the mornings it's very nice I
put two scoops of powder into my little
blender type thing Add Water sometimes a
bit of milk and that gives me what I
need but also for lunch I like using the
huel hot and savory product they've got
which basically you add boiling water to
this container of stuff and you can make
yourself like a they've got a really
good cheese pasta type one which is
which is my favorite thing and again
also all of these are nutritionally
complete meals they're all vegan they
all have all these nutrients and
vitamins and minerals and stuff and
they're often reasonably high protein as
well and it's also ridiculously cost
effective like one of these meals is one
pound 68 for a 400 calorie meal which is
like a tenth of the price of what I
would be ordering from deliveroo instead
and to really heal is a perfect
companion for a busy life where you want
to get a lot of things done and you
don't if you don't necessarily have a
lot of time to cook a healthy meal and
deal with all the prep and all the
shopping and all the cleanup then heal
is a great addition to your life rather
than a replacement for all of the meals
in your life anyway if that sounds
appeal Street and you want to try out
heal then if you head over to heel.com
forward slash deep dive that URL is a
special URL which will give you a free
t-shirt and a free Shaker thing with
your first order and so yeah head over
to heel.com forward slash deep dive and
thank you so much Hill for sponsoring
this episode we're going to take a very
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor brilliant.org I've
been using brilliant for a few years now
and it's a fantastic online platform for
corsairs in maths and science and
computer science now one of my life
philosophies is that we should all
Endeavor to be lifelong Learners if we
want because it's good for the mind it's
good for the body it's good for our
general happiness and health and
Brilliant is a perfect resource from
this because you can really level up
your own thinking in terms of maths and
science and computer science without
having to spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars on extra degrees or extra
courses now the courses are brilliant
are actually great because they take
what could be dry Topics in math and
science and computer science and they
turn them into really interesting
interactive and enjoyable kind of
experiences where you learn a little bit
and then you apply it in practice and
then you learn a bit more and then you
put it into practice and it's almost
like the system that we used to use in
our tutorials back when I was at
University of Cambridge where you would
learn a little thing and then you'd be
paired with a world-class expert in the
thing and then be asking you questions
and you'd be kind of figuring it out
together rather than being spoon fed
information like we're normally taught
in school each lesson on brilliant is
broken up into 15-minute bite-sized
chunks and so wherever you are in your
day you can find a little little bit of
time you can go on the app and you can
level up your brain rather than
scrolling social media or whatever the
other default activity might be and it's
pretty cool as well because they're
constantly updating the library of
courses for example they've recently
released a course introduction to
algebra and this is like a visual
representation of algebraic thinking now
I thought I understood algebra because I
did maths in school but actually the way
that brilliant explains it with kind of
the stories and the puzzles and the
interactive exercises you go along has
really given me a new understanding of
algebra that I just didn't have before
and that maybe you would need to do like
a math degree to actually get that grasp
of what algebra actually is and why it's
so important so if any of that stands up
your street and you'd like to level up
your thinking and your knowledge in
maths or science or computer science
then head over to brilliant.org forward
slash deep dive and the first 200 people
to click that link which will be in the
show notes and in the video description
as well will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you so
much brilliant for sponsoring this
episode and let's get right back to the
podcast do you find
like for example your work uh your book
The Man's Guide to women
is that
surely that's that's not
exactly identical to the woman's guide
to men
um there there would be different advice
that I guess you would give to men and
you'd give to and and you'd give to give
to women so I guess like
what I'm asking is
what are some of the kind of
men's specific advice that you would
give let's say if I was if if I was
asking you hey you know what are the
common mistakes that men tend to make in
relationships and then we can talk later
about what are the common mistakes that
women tend to make in relationships what
is what does that divide look like
you see
um well first of all men know that women
have a cycle right so they have a
menstrual cycle through the first
you know I don't know 25 years maybe of
their adult life and
um that's happening regularly every
month
usually and I don't think men understand
so well uh what happens to women when
all those hormones are flooding their
bodies from that menstrual cycle what
can happen
um there's more fluid accumulated in the
body due to hormonal changes and that
fluid affects all of the body the brain
included and the woman typically will
become more sensitive so she'll be more
sensitive emotionally she may take
things a little harder than during the
time when she's not about to have her
period for example
um so you've got to watch that kind of
Swing of moods
um and
pay attention to that and not
necessarily believe that some of the
stuff that she says a few days before
her period is exactly how she feels
because it may not be it's going to vary
over time
another thing is to realize that
um women
are basically they're the custodians of
the relationship
so women typically see ways to improve
the relationship they're always watching
for is this a good relationship is it
loving enough is it kind enough is there
enough friendship is there enough
intimacy am I being listened to
Etc uh and so they'll bring up issues
more commonly than men men can Coast on
yeah this is this is fine this is okay
but women tend not to and so they're
going to bring up issues more regularly
just to make sure the relationship stays
on track
and that can make men feel like whatever
I do it's not enough
you know I just God I try and try and
try and it's never enough and that's one
of the things women have to be sensitive
to in men so men are trying very hard to
be the best husbands they can be the
best fathers they can be and they're
working hard at it and sometimes they
may not understand what a woman needs
for example if a woman comes home
stressed from her work
the man thinks as he listens to her that
he should offer her a solution to
whatever she stressed about wrong that's
going to feel condescending to the woman
because it's another way of saying
you're not smart enough to figure out a
solution so let me give you one right
that's the message she may take from it
the thing that men need to do in that
situation is to not offer Solutions
unless the woman has specifically asked
for that and instead
just listen to what she's saying try to
feel a little bit of what she's
expressing ask her questions like what's
the most upsetting part about this for
you or help me understand how this made
you feel so anxious I want I want to
really get inside that and know that
and then give words of empathy and
empathy is going to look like no wonder
you felt so angry wow yeah I would have
been upset too that sounds terrible so
you're really stepping into the
partner's World emotionally and hanging
out in there with her
empathizing with her so she doesn't feel
so alone with those feelings not feeling
alone is the big stress reducer not
getting a solution to a problem
it's not feeling alone
you mentioned earlier when we were
talking that recently you've done a lot
of research on gay and lesbian couples
I wonder what's been some of the
surprising things that you found from
that research I guess compared to
heterosexual couples
yeah one of the things that we that we
discovered is that uh gay and lesbian
couples are a lot less defensive
um when their partner presents a point
of view then uh male female
relationships
they have more of a sense of humor their
uh they're less critical and less
defensive so we have a lot to learn from
those relationships uh you know we think
well you know
since you know they're they're the
minority their relationships you know
they're not the the majority of
relationships then there must be
something wrong with them something
defective we found in fact that many
ways they were Superior to heterosexual
relationships there wasn't as much
competition and
dominance struggling for you know like
who's going to win this argument it was
much more equal and you know much more
understanding more and and they had a
better sense of humor about themselves
uh so it wasn't it wasn't as much War
the way it is between men and women and
you know and they didn't get into these
standoffs they would you know they
basically would say oh well that's an
interesting point of view let's talk
about your point of view and you know
here's what I think you're saying and is
that right you know so they were just
much better communicators than you know
the Battle of the Sexes which typifies a
lot of heterosexual uh relationships the
standoff you know where there's a power
struggle they didn't have as much of
that and and that was really interesting
to discover one of the biggest biggest
biggest most important differences
between men and women in heterosexual
relationships it's about sex
the biggest difference is that women
need emotional closeness in order to be
open sexually
men
typically don't they may use sex as a
way to feel emotionally close
man let me explain that
as one can imagine women have a history
of thousands of years of being raped
sexually abused hurt through sex
and
we feel it in our bones even if we
haven't experienced it ourselves we
don't feel safe in the world
we do not you can take a room of people
give them an example of you're walking
into a underground garage how many of
you feel afraid almost all the women
will raise their hands almost none of
the men will
I mean it's just wow it's really a huge
discrepancy so when a woman is being
most vulnerable which is typically
during sexual intimacy she really needs
to feel safe
particularly if she's had any kind of
sexual abuse in her background and we
know that at the minimum one out of four
women by the age of 18 has experienced
sexual abuse or molestation and it's
those are the only ones who report it
it's probably a higher percentage than
that so women need to feel emotionally
close in order to be sexually open and
Men we need as women we need to
understand that for men a lot of times
you know men may feel like oh it's too
childlike to just ask for a cuddle ask
for a hug
so will be manly and we'll go for sex
which gives us you know all the touch
and all the hugging and you know all
that contact that we need as well as
pleasure so
um women need to understand that uh
their men are looking for emotional
closeness through sex
and to be as giving as they can
yeah so on that note
um you often hear a like in in Cosmo
magazine and stuff you know that the
classic advice
for men is
hey if you you know if you do the dishes
then she's going to be more open to
to having sex you know that that kind of
direction of stuff to what extent is
there is there truth in that is is that
related to this idea of it it signals
emotional intimacy kind of thing
yeah absolutely true
um it's uh
you know in general if if uh housework
is not just women's work if you're
sharing in the housework and child care
especially especially child care and you
know we need fathers to really be much
more involved with their children
because it's good for both sons and
daughters fathers make a unique
contribution
to the intellectual and Social
Development of the both sons and
daughters so that sharing you know the
sort of everyday maintenance of the home
with women means that women aren't doing
a second shift when they come home from
work they have another shift they have
to do all the housework and child care
and all of that and that usually really
separates men and women uh one study
done at UCLA at this loan center found
that with dual career couples in Los
Angeles they spend less than 10 percent
of an evening in the same room and they
talk to each other around 35 minutes a
week
mostly about errands
so you know there a lot of these
marriages you know intimacy is not being
maintained the relationship doesn't come
first so if both men and women are
involved with children and they're
involved with the house uh then it
doesn't feel to a woman like she has to
do a second shift when she comes home
from work and he's more of a partner and
again it gets to back to what Julie was
saying you know women need to feel close
and to feel safe and then the situation
can be erotic as long as there's not a
big to-do list in her mind and like the
dog needs to be taken for a walk and you
know the kids you know kids are asking
for milk read them read me another story
mommy you know they're both in it
together and so sex becomes a whole
different kind of thing it's really the
expression of the love that's there it's
not another chore that the woman has to
do
to what extent is it important that a
relationship have a
kind of
CEO and c-o-o kind of or like you know
captain and first mate or like leader
and someone is sort of equal but like
there's a a leader in the relationship
is is that something that you guys have
seen is important in relationships
there are there are many different
Arrangements in terms of decision making
and Power in a relationship and the
important thing is it doesn't really
matter whether you know she's the
captain or he's the captain or nobody's
the captain they decide by consensus as
long as it feels fair to both people as
long as it feels just and fair uh then
any Arrangement can work so there's no
one better kind of arrangement in terms
of his his being the captain her being
the captain nobody being the captain uh
it has to feel fair and just that's
that's the thing that matters the most
and have you got any tips for navigating
like for for example one thing I've
heard a lot of um friends who are in
long-term marriages say that it's really
useful to actually
sit down and actively divide up the
chores to be like I'm always taking the
trash out you're always done dealing
with this I'm always doing dealing with
that do you guys have any any tips on
how to I guess navigate the logistics of
a relationship in an effective way
wait a minute
let's let's divide it down a little bit
the logistics of a relationship there's
a whole lot of logistics right so
um
it it really does help to sit down kind
of have a meeting right kind of a state
of the union meeting and uh to talk
about how you're going to divvy up the
Labor uh the labor of taking care of the
house taking care of the kids taking
care of the yard taking care of the
in-laws you know
um talking about entertaining and how
much you want to entertain versus just
have private time
um and part of that this is one of my
favorite things to do Ali is to create
what we call rituals of connection and
rituals of connection are
um
activities that you do together with
your partner that are pre-designed
they're pre-planned and they're agreed
upon so you co-design a ritual of
connection uh and many of you are
probably already doing some of those
so for example here are some rituals of
connection the way that you greet each
other first thing in the morning when
you wake up
the way that you greet each other if
you're working you know apart and you
reunite at the end of the day
um do you have breakfast together every
morning do you have dinners together do
you typically go out on a date one night
a week or do you go out for brunch every
Sunday do you uh during the ski season
of course you guys are in London it's a
little different but
um during an active season do you go
skiing every weekend for such and such a
number of months do you watch murder
mysteries at dinner and uh and they have
to be British
they're the best
so John and I have this great ritual
after dinner we have what we call a
cuddle couch whiz which is a a kind of a
case Lounge it's kind of a chaise you
know comfy Lounge that's about wide
enough for a person and a half and so
between the two of us we fill it up
really well and
um we'll watch British murder mysteries
in the evening when cuddle and cuddle
and you know we're squished together our
dog often joins us so he's in there too
and uh we'll watch you know rich people
getting murdered and it's very
satisfying so
um that's a ritual of connection yeah
that's a ritual of connection
um yeah
so you know any and rituals of
connection can be big too they can be
how our birthday is celebrated in our
family
how are the religious holidays
celebrated in our family right if you
have a Sabbath every weekend how is that
celebrated you know Etc
um how do you celebrate vacations what
kind of vacations do you go on
um we have an annual honeymoon that we
do right and we we've read this
in the same bed and breakfast uh one so
for 23 years we've been taking about 10
days
bring our kayak and and we sit and talk
to each other for those 10 days about
what was the year like what did you hate
about last year what did you love about
last year and what do you want next year
to be like and we take a lot of time to
really do that while we're having fun
kayaking and hiking and eating out in
really good restaurants and going to the
Farmers Market on Saturday and things
like that so that's one of our rituals
of connection that we love yeah it's
really fun so when our daughter turned
eight years old she went away to camp
for a couple of weeks and we decided we
should go to Camp too and that's when it
started right
yeah
excellent that sounds that sounds
amazing um one of the one of the things
that my partner and I started doing
fairly early on in our relationship it's
it's been about 18 months now
um we read a book called how to not die
alone by Logan Yuri who we had on the
podcast
Logan is a good friend actual yeah yeah
no she's great she's wonderful yeah we
adore her and and in the book she talked
about doing uh relationship reviews and
these included these questionnaires and
so almost from kind of day one we've
been doing every few weeks the
relationship review
and everyone I'm all my friends I
mentioned this to like half of them say
oh my gosh that I need that in my life
and the other half say wait what that's
that's a bit weird how can he possibly
do a relationship with you um but it's
been one of the most I think worthwhile
Parts about kind of growing together
because we co-decided on what 10
questions we were going to use we have a
little notion template that we've been
filling in since for the last 18 months
and it's super nice just to give that a
I mean I've I've I've certainly found it
super helpful to make space in what's an
otherwise fairly busy life to be like
hey you know how are you feeling what's
something that I did that maybe made you
feel bad that I didn't realize would
make you feel bad and I've just it's
been such a great kind of learning curve
from from my end but also those little
things that feel like they're not worth
bringing up in the moment we always know
that okay at some point in the next
couple of weeks we're going to sit down
and actively talk about stuff so
you know if it doesn't need if it's not
a major thing that needs to be discussed
right now it can always be pushed to to
the review do you guys do anything like
that is that something that you would
recommend people do
yeah we totally do we have
um and we often uh say that our clients
should do this but we tell everybody to
do this uh it's called a state of the
union meeting so you know we have a
different name for it and uh the way
that that is typically conducted is each
person the the meeting begins with each
person giving three to five
appreciations
um for things the other person has done
uh and saying thank you and these are
typically things that maybe haven't been
uh thanked for earlier
so each person gives each other these
appreciations then the middle of the
meeting is bringing up anything that
they need to solve any decisions that
need to be made any uh past regrettable
incidents that need to be processed the
way we talked about earlier today
um
uh so that you know that's kind of the
meaty part of
the conversation needs can be brought up
then to you know what the person really
needs
um and so on and then the meeting ends
with the question
um that each person poses to the other
what is one way that I can help you feel
more loved in the coming week
and that is just you know that's really
keeps relationships on track
I'm taking copious notes this is this is
incredibly useful
um do you guys have I guess do you guys
have a ritual around it do you like go
out for dinner and then do it or is it
and is it like an ad hoc thing that
happens is it like a weekly monthly
thing like what what are the what's the
context around the state of the union
meeting
you know um everybody can create their
own context right I mean if you have six
kids running around the house you might
want to go out
um uh if you don't you can do it at home
on a Sunday morning
um you can certainly go out to dinner
you can do it while you're taking a walk
I mean that's really a nice way to have
that kind of joining together and
talking so you know whatever you're
comfortable with it's similar to uh what
we did in our book eight dates where we
created conversations with a few
questions and preparation thinking you
know things to think about for each day
and then people discussing these deeper
topics on each date uh and we give
suggestions for what that date could
look like given that particular topic
for the week
um and of course people have the freedom
to do whatever they want to do but it's
it's really you know a lovely thing to
do to talk about these deeper topics and
to have a way to do that changing gears
a little bit
um what do you guys see as the function
of marriage in uh sort of modern secular
liberal kind of in my environment
that's a great one yeah well
um well are you talking about marriage
versus a committed relationship where
you're living together or just a
long-term yeah I guess yeah I guess kind
of some some people would say that the
institution of marriage is outdated and
we no longer need the government to step
in and get involved etc etc what's wrong
with just being in a committed long-term
relationship where we're not married
yeah I you know the uh the research on
this and this is a new field that has
emerged in the past 50 years called
social epidemiology is really it's a
candy uh is really looking at uh what
the benefits are of a good relationship
it emerged out of asking questions you
know what what can you do to live longer
and uh and this the the initial
questions thought well you probably just
need to have a diet that doesn't have as
much cholesterol and exercise but when
they actually did the research
it was started by uh Leonard Sim at
Berkeley and his student uh Lisa
um what's her name it's okay yeah anyway
uh
I I'm blocking on her last name and what
they found was that relationships were
what really predicted longevity and so
close relationships were the most
important thing very close friendships
your relationships with your children
and your love relationships and if the
relationships were high in quality if
people were really happy with the
relationship and uh and the marriage
really made them happy they would live
10 to 15 years longer and Not only would
they live longer but they would recover
from illness quicker and they'd have
fewer illnesses and their children would
do better in life so it turns out that
if relationships have certain
ingredients they confer all of these
wonderful uh things you know they you
know people become wealthier they
they're happier in life
and it doesn't really matter if they're
married or not if there's Commitment if
there's trust in the relationship and
usually that is part of the wedding vows
so so you know the institution of
marriage is a way of kind of ensuring
that these qualities are there in the
relationship that are life-giving
health-giving and really very healthy
for our children and their development
so it's not really the institution of
marriage it's the quality of the
relationship that makes the difference
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by trading212. now people ask me all
the time for advice about investing
because I've made a bunch of videos
about it on the YouTube channel and my
advice for most people is generally
invest in Broad stock market index funds
which is exactly what you can do
completely for free with trading 212.
it's a great app that lets you trade
stocks and funds and ETFs and foreign
exchange if you really want to and one
of the great things about the app is
that if you're new to the world of
investing you can actually invest with
fake money you don't have to put real
money in they've got a practice mode
where you invest fake money and then it
actually tracks what the market is doing
in real time so you can see had I
invested 100 pounds into this thing what
would my return have been X weeks or X
months further down the line once you've
got some comfort with that then it's
super easy to deposit money into your
trading tube into account you can use
Apple pay like I do initially or you can
use a direct bank transfer and then once
the money is in your trading 212 account
then you can invest it in basically
whatever you want now if you're based in
the UK you might be familiar with the
concept of an Isa which is an individual
savings account which is basically a
tax-free wrapper that you can put money
in you can put twenty thousand pounds in
every year up to twenty thousand pounds
and it resets every April and then all
that money can grow and it's completely
tax-free for the rest of your life and
if you want to sign up for an iso you
can sign up for one completely for free
also on trading212 so if you haven't yet
filled up your eyes allowance or at
least put some money into your Isa for
this year that might be a good step
forward the app also lets you Auto
invest which is a great thing because
then you can automatically invest a
percentage of your paycheck into the
thing every month and so if you haven't
yet started with investing and you want
to give it a go then you can download
the app on the App Store and if you use
the coupon code Ali Ali at the checkout
that will give you a totally free share
worth up to 100 pounds it's available on
iPhone and Android and you can check it
out by typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode this episode is very kindly
brought to you by wework now this is
particularly exciting for me because I
have been a paying full paying customer
of wework for the last two years now I
discovered it during you know when the
pandemic was in the on the verge of
being lifted and I'd spent like the
whole year just sort of sitting in my
room making YouTube videos but then I
discovered wework and I was a member me
and Angus my team members we were
members of the wework in Cambridge and
they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all-access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I'll get some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I've made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being in an environment
almost like a library but kind of nicer
because there's like a little bit of
soft music in the background and there's
other kind of startup Bros and creators
and stuff in in there as well and it's
just my absolute favorite co-working
space of all time it's super easy to
book a desk or book a conference room
using the app and it's a great place to
meet up with team member if you're going
to collaborate and you'll live in
different places they've got unlimited
tea and coffee and herbal teas and
drinks on tap and they've got soundproof
boots in which they take Zoom calls and
meetings anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend wework like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode when it comes to and I'm it is
great because I'm asking all the
questions that I want to know the answer
to when it when it comes to let's say
before
um proposing to someone or before making
the active commitment to be in a
long-term relationship
is there a consensus on like how long
you should date for or like when when do
you know that someone is right to get
married to
okay
uh John and I for example uh we were a
little older when we met uh but John
proposed in five months
which is you know relatively short I've
seen people who've proposed after a day
uh and but I had a database that's true
I had dated 60 women
in one summer just kind of making it my
purpose to find a partner and Julie was
number 61. and so she was such an
outlier for me that I knew very quickly
that I wanted to spend my life with her
you cutie he's so cute number six
everything felt right it was so easy to
talk yeah but you know is there
something so much special about number
61 is that my claim to fame number 61.
you totally were an outlier compared to
all the other women and you should have
heard about the other women I mean they
were like very interesting people and so
yeah one talked about murdering you know
having fantasies of murdering people
it's just like oh my God so
um yeah
so it there is no uh time frame I think
the thing that's more important is
looking at the qualities of the person
uh and do they fit who you're looking
for
um not that anybody is going to be a
perfect match I mean everybody has lots
and lots and lots of different matches
that are possible out there in the world
you know we're seven and a half billion
people there's a lot of matches for you
uh but there's no one perfect person but
is this person kind are they respectful
not only to you but one of the things
that I tell my single clients is look
for how this person treats
uh servers at a restaurant for example
or the bus driver
uh of the bus you're getting on how do
they treat people of all walks of life
how do they even treat homeless people
um not just people at their status level
but people below their status for their
cat so
one of the things I loved about Julie
was she had this cat named sassy and
when I when I took sassy off her
favorite chair and put her on the ground
first time Julie cooked a meal for me in
her apartment we didn't know each other
very well the cat went right into the
kitchen and complained to Julie and I
could hear the cat saying who is this
jerk who just took me off my favorite
chair and put me on the ground I don't
like this guy and and Julie comforted
the cat I could tell this cat was very
well treated she was very kind to this
cat
oh great I love that cat that was a
great cat
yep
yeah so kind caring respectful uh also
reliable are they really reliable do
they follow through with what they say
they're going to do
um and one of the best questions if it's
somebody who's been in other
relationships uh in the past or even
other marriages is to ask them how come
you broke up and if they blame the
breakup totally on the other person
you're in trouble forget it
they're not owning responsibility for
their part in whatever went wrong and
that's a bad sign because they may do
the same thing with you
nice
on a some someone similar thing and the
answer to this might well be no but uh
is there any consensus on
what sort of age Gap is like ideal if we
look at the stats is there an age Gap
that's ideal
or is that just a yeah no you know the
only uh statistic that I know like that
that actually is held up worldwide is
that it's a mistake to marry a woman
before she's 20 years old
so women once they once they're 20 years
old
they're
marriage is a much more likely to be
stable
wow that's interesting that's a
worldwide phenomenon that's the only age
thing I know of that uh has really held
up in the research yeah you know I've
seen clinically
um I've seen you know probably a
thousand couples or something over many
many years of treating people uh and I
think
I've seen every age variation there is
I've seen women who are 20 years older
than the partner the man if it's a
heterosexual relationship I've seen you
know gay and lesbian relationships with
big age gaps in every direction uh
sometimes men are much much older than
women as long as they can negotiate the
different
developmental needs they have in their
particular age you know for example
um if a 60 year old fellow marries a 25
year old woman well that 25 year old
woman is probably very highly energetic
is wanting to go out do stuff you know
if she's a little more extroverted uh
you know go to bars maybe or go out and
dancing or go do you know bicycling on
the weekend or whatever
and
you hope that there are some
intersections you know some overlap
between uh the
interests of the older person in the
interests of the younger person
so
um that's you know it's more about that
it's also shared history
um people for example in the United
States who are over let's say 35 40
something like that all remember 9 11
when the Trade Towers in New York City
were bombed and we all had the
experience of that but a 20 year old is
not
so does that make a difference in how
Society is viewed or how dangerous the
world feels so you know those are all
things that can be talked about and
understood you don't have to be
identical you shouldn't be in fact it's
not going to work it's too boring but to
be able to talk about those differences
and there will be some in every
relationship is what's most important
okay nice
um so Julie you've got a
um a background as a relationship
therapist from my understanding um what
are the contexts in which you would
recommend a couple or an individual see
a relationships therapist or a
relationships coach
uh well first of all
um let's see
I would suggest first of all that people
uh who are having conflicts that never
get resolved and they end up trying to
sweep them under the rug or uh those
conflicts blow up into huge battles uh
and there never is any progress
um that is a couple that needs to see
somebody
if there's been an affair that needs uh
help oftentimes sometimes if there's
been a terrible tragedy like a child has
been lost you know something like that
um people really need you know a lot of
support sometimes to navigate that and
to uh have the relationship be
supportive of each person through that
process
sometimes people will feel very very
emotionally distant from each other
they've grown apart you know not through
intention it's just happened you know
maybe through their Career Development
or something
um and they don't they don't really know
who their partner is anymore that's a
good time to go seek help
yeah in fact in the uh California
divorce mediation project with very
large project looking at Divorce by two
researchers XI Jin Kelly one of the two
people who did that research
um they found that people drifting apart
was the major reason for divorce it
wasn't Affairs it wasn't you know the
kind of thing you think you know like
conflict about money would be the major
thing it said they drifted apart and so
if you find yourself being lonely in the
relationship that's an excellent marker
that you need a therapist to help you
yeah perfect that's right
do you think there's any value in
preemptive relationship therapy almost
like getting a personal trainer even
before you're out of shape just to keep
things in shape is that something that
you guys have seen and
yeah sure you know pre-marital
counseling that's what you're talking
about or pre-commitment counseling sure
I mean uh religious institutions have
been doing that you know for decades uh
if not centuries so
um absolutely that's preemptive is a
great word
um yes uh people do come in uh to get
help and look for tools
um to have on board to have skills on
board because inevitably over time if
they stay together there's going to be
difficult situations it's what life
throws us right so we want to be able to
navigate those carefully and gently and
compassionately right uh and not have
those turn into regrettable incidents
nice
um I'd love to talk a little bit about
the new book uh the love prescription
seven days to more intimacy connection
and joy I've started reading that on my
Kindle and I've got the physical copy
arriving in the next in the next couple
of days
um but it's interesting because one of
the one of the claims in the book or at
least in the in the blurb is that there
is a formula for a good relationship and
if you just I almost the vibe that I got
was that hey if you follow the formula
and just do these seven things across
these seven days or however however long
it takes you will just almost magically
improve the quality of your relationship
uh so I wonder if you can just kind of
Riff on that a little bit like what is
this form formula for love
yeah
sure so one of the things is being nice
to one another
so you know all right giving apart a
compliments uh you know uh catching a
partner doing something right and and
communicating that communicating respect
and affection and words letting your
partner know how attractive they are to
you and how irresistible they seem at
times you know those that kind of
positivity is very very critical another
one is
turning toward it turns out to be a very
powerful thing in a relationship so you
know in our apartment lab we saw 130
newlywed couples and followed them for
six years
we discovered that a lot of time when
they're just kind of hanging out in this
apartment lab one person will try to get
the other person's attention or share
something humorous or you know some
interesting story that they've heard or
are reading about and then they try to
connect they make a bid for connection
and then the cameras in the lab always
swung to the other person to see the
response and there were one of three
responses turning toward which was you
know really acknowledging the connection
you know one person might say Oh What a
Beautiful boat that is you know going by
and if the other person said yeah huh uh
that was turning toward if they didn't
respond at all that was turning away or
if they responded irritably would you be
quiet I'm trying to read that was
turning against
so when we followed couples the the 17
couples who divorced one another after
uh six years after the wedding uh when
we looked back six years earlier they
had turned toward these bids only 33
percent of the time
whereas the couples who are still
together six years earlier had turned
toward the bids 86 percent of the time
you know a huge difference
and we also discovered that turning
toward is like an emotional bank account
that you build when you really connect
with your partner when your partner
wants to connect with you then
during conflict
you have more of a sense of humor about
yourself and about one another you can
laugh together and you can be
affectionate even when you disagreeing
and it reduces physiological arousal so
turning toward is another one that's
very very powerful and when people
become aware of that as a tool of
connecting then the relationship
improves quite dramatically right so in
this book what we're doing is each day
we're giving couples little thing to do
little 10 minute thing to do every
single day like one day we'll be giving
compliments you know really expressing
fondness and admiration a second day
will be look for what your partner is
doing right
and not just wrong right and point it
out and say thank you to your partner
you know third is listening you know
talking about your needs with one
another what do you need and we
emphasize you should bring up your needs
as a positive need rather than a
negative need and what that means is
that you ask for what you do want
not what you don't like or you resent
don't bring that up because that's going
to sound like criticism instead flip it
on its head and say I would love it if
you clean the dishes three times a week
that would be such a big help to me
that's a positive me so uh people
present you know on I forget which day
they talk about one need they have with
their partner that can allow their
partner to shine for them
it's not a criticism it's the opposite
right another one is honoring each
other's dreams so talk about what maybe
deeply held dream you have for something
you want to do something you want to
experience something you want to feel
whatever it is
share that with your partner and really
listen to what your partner says about
that question too
so you know there what we hope to see if
people practice this every day for seven
days is that from before they started it
to the end of the week they'll see a
little bit of change maybe little
something feels different and they can
talk about which one of those little
prescriptions really made a difference
for them
now it doesn't mean everything gets
fixed in seven days and then you can go
back to being whoever you were before no
it's instead that you're learning how to
do something a little different that
deepens the Friendship deepens emotional
intimacy which of course opens up to you
know what you know more sexual intimacy
and helps you when you have to talk
about conflict continue those practices
especially the ones you found the best
for you and your partner
and you'll see over time you know the
relationship is doing this over time big
change
fantastic and we'll put links down in
the video description in the show notes
wherever people are listening or
watching to this to the to the new book
um I'd love to also I don't have kids
yet uh anything that couples and I guess
I'm asking the question selfishly
anything that people should keep in mind
before having kids should is is there
stuff like ducks that you need to line
up before making that big plunge is
there like a right time
any any tips on that front
well first of all there's never a right
time to have kids
you know I mean in the sense that uh
there's always something going on in
your life right uh you're doing work and
you're doing a career or you know you
want to go do an adventure you want to
go travel you know whatever so you
decide to have kids when you really
really want kids and you prepare
yourself
by talking a lot about
um really important questions for
example how should we discipline our kid
do we use corporal punishment or not
that's a big one or should we raise our
kid within a particular religious
institution or not
um
if our kid wants to change genders or be
transsexual will we support that or not
as our kid gets older
um how about who's going to take the
Sleep shift
who's gonna do nights
um
which is really important how will we
handle nights how will we handle nights
right
um and uh lining up a support system is
really a good idea having friends
um who have already had kids
you know maybe young kids uh and uh you
can go to them and say oh my God I
haven't slept in like 12 nights straight
I'm going out of my mind how did you
survive and they can help support you
you know through the process
let me provide a little different answer
so the first book that Julie and I wrote
together was called and baby Makes Three
and it was based on that newlywed study
that we did as many of the couples
became pregnant and had their first
child together we followed them over
time we studied the babies and their
development and what we discovered was
that at least in the United States there
seems to be true two-thirds of couples
have this big drop in relationship
happiness in the first three years of
their baby's life their first baby's
life and one-third don't so Julie and I
studied the difference between the
one-third and the two-thirds group and
we designed a workshop called bringing
baby home
uh which was one that we wished we had
when we had our baby because we we
brought the baby home and Julie said
what do we do now and I said well
against the videotape at the hospital so
we put it in and it had nothing about
babies it was all about all the services
the hospital offered so we actually
developed that you know videotape and
manual that we wished we had when we
first brought our baby home and in that
Workshop that bringing baby home
Workshop in just 10 hours 80 percent of
couples avoid that drop in relationship
happiness just by looking at things like
how do we play with babies how important
are fathers in the development of kids
and how should they be involved and how
do we maintain intimacy sexual intimacy
emotional intimacy how do we make
decisions better as we deal with
conflict better in just 10 hours
everything changed for these couples
it's our biggest effect that we've ever
had in in programmatic research so you
really want to do this Workshop before
you have a baby
and it's online actually it can be
streamed online uh at The gottman
Institute
right I'll put a link to that down below
as well and I'll definitely be checking
that out when when the time is right
um guys I just I just wanted to end by a
bit of a random question you guys have
written a bunch of books um what does
your writing and I I guess what is your
kind of writing process look like and I
ask because I'm kind of in the midst of
editing for my first book and I ca I
want to do this writing thing as like a
long-term gig and you guys have
absolutely done the writing thing as a
long as a long-term gig so what does the
process look like and do you have any
tips for new uh and aspiring writers
uh well uh typically uh John will write
a rough draft
um chapter by chapter and then I will
then he'll give it to me I'll probably
reorganize it rewrite sections of it
edit it
um into a second draft give it back to
him
uh he usually rubber stamps it or he may
fill in a little bit uh of things that
I've missed uh and that's it
we're off and running except that we
have to do the research first yeah sure
so uh you know it's important to go to
the library
and read you know what the research is
if you haven't done the research
yourself uh
so for example one of my favorite books
is come as you are Emily nagoski wrote
that book about how to maintain a great
sexual relationship and she went to the
library she actually did her research on
what makes relationships work sexually
and so that's a very very important part
of it quite often people write books
just on the basis of their own intuition
and their own experience and quite often
they come up with bad advice
I myself
as a source of hypotheses or is I'm
completely unreliable I've kept track of
my ideas and my hypotheses are wrong
sixty percent of the time
so if I didn't do the research I think I
was right 100 of the time but most of
mostly I'm wrong
but what I think how the reality should
be
so do the research that's the important
thing I think
and then right right so people really
enjoy reading it
nice guys thank you so much this has
been absolutely wonderful uh where can
people go to learn more about the work
that you do and um yeah your your
workshops and things
uh they can go to
www.gotman g-o-t-t-m-a-n.com
and everything is right there
amazing and we'll put links to all of
that stuff as well about the Goldman
Institute everything will be linked down
below
probably they can also go to the App
Store and type in gottman card decks and
download a free
that they can have on their phones with
all kinds of card decks for improving
sexual relationship for helping them
talk about what they need and how they
feel and and all of that is downloadable
for free
fantastic I have I didn't know that
those existed but I will I'm just
checking it on the other store now I've
got my card decks for the iPad oh so
good
we'll be installing that right now so
yeah guys thank you so much this has
been wonderful um thanks for um giving
us your time and your expertise and
thanks again for the amazing work you've
done over the the several several
decades I know I benefited from your
work and there are so many of my friends
who have read your stuff and just
have cited it to death in in
conversation so thank you so much for
that
um and uh have a great day
thank you so much Ellie and also uh we
want to wish you well in your
relationship right
thank you we're on a good road here yeah
we're checking out all of the various
books that you've got as the time as the
time comes
sounds good okay thank you so much
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye